and you're here to talk about apple
we're delighted that you're here because
as we've seen over the past several days
Apple stock has been taking a beating
you've got 175 dollar price targets
still if i'm not mistaken an apple what
give it although you brought it down
what gives you confidence that apple can
deliver because a lot of people are
losing that confidence in a semi it's a
white-knuckle period ever since the
earnings a few weeks ago with the iphone
number that was you massively strong but
didn't beat whisper expectations the
quarter yeah in terms of the june court
i feel this is a three-month sort of
battleground period but ultimately I
believe right now thirty percent of
iphone users of upgrade 26 when that
goes to seventy five eighty percent next
year you get the 6s coming in the fall I
do believe this is going to be what I
view is just a massive opportunity to
own an apple you're gonna see just like
today a lot appears yelling fire in a
crowded theater technicals breaking at
the end of you take a step back eight
times X cash for a company that I all
doing bleep streets under estimating
growth the next year and a half by
fifteen twenty percent well mostly thing
to follow this stuff I have my iphone
right I pulled out my iphone you're a
credit guy you know how much of this
matters to you uh it doesn't really
matter except for a sentiment I mean
Apple is a premier credit bellwether
right which is oh my god they borrow so
cheaply what I will say though about
apple wood which I think really
resonated with me and by the way I'm saw
Bob Iger at CEO magazines dinner last
week and I love his articulated plan for
the future the stocks down ten but this
guy is brilliant I think you could turn
it but I think it relates a little bit
to Apple where the CEO is he as
innovative as the former CEO and can
Apple managed that massive innovation
that they have for the dat past decade
the future I've really come to respect
great CEOs trabajo and that's been sort
of proved me right in terms of what
cooks done and I think now we go into a
2 dot 0 period I mean he's proving it
with iphone 6 we've seen it with the
stock now it's really about 6s and these
new product areas in terms of streaming
TV potentially the Apple watch has also
come out softer than expected which has
been a headwind so Dan do you think that
Apple is this this period
the white knuckle ride is you describe
it it's going to mirror what Apple
investors went through back in 2013 when
the stock started the year out and
eighty bottoms mid year more or less
where we are now below 60 and then was
back up to 80 by the end of the year now
of course and I'm talking on a
split-adjusted basis it's now at 114 box
viewed as a similar trend and also you
can see the company also from
accelerated buybacks using some a two
hundred billion more in terms during
this period we've seen in the past when
a stock has a free fall with Apple that
they've been able to take advantage but
but we're now start having even coming
here the cab driver was talking negative
about Apple so that could be potentially
a sign that we've sorted bomb but it did
just like you said it becomes more it's
a consumer to retail name this is really
the golden sort of standard for
technology I view this is more of a
correction and they proved in September
in December going to success rather than
the start of I find the embarrassing
when someone compared to nokia to da
dough you know as someone that you think
they should have returned a whole bunch
of capital and borrowed a lot of take a
look at lashauwn right into the TV
anchor you know let me just ask you a
question right here I love it I mean 91
proposed a writer in his letter to Apple
as a major shareholder that they recap
it out and they really could get better
or are weeds for their shareholders if
they change their capital one XP won't
the 200 billion a announced I think was
just the starter now that would they do
face serious questions because as much
as China's growth and that's really fuel
in the the engine for Apple now it does
really be do they change some that
pollinate you an accelerated by back
what do we see on the cash strategy
increased acquisition by our tech
companies so afraid of capital
efficiency okay well some of it has to
do with the fact that a lot of their
cash is trapped Offshore's and they
haven't paid taxes which we can talk
about fairness and Taxation maybe
another time but it as that repatriates
right or they can borrow against it to
pay dividends they can make a more
efficient capital structure which I know
our government has to fix I know orrin
hatch is working on that for example so
that's a whole nother topic and I am
concerned about corporate tax rates and
things like that but apples probably in
one of those Quagmire's right yeah with
a lot of gas yards offshore and that's
why
you know I think right now they're going
through a period trying to figure out
what the next step is after at 200
billion but i do believe next few weeks
in accelerated by back could sort of
kick in and you're going to see you're
going to see more throw in the towel
you're gonna see investors saying this
could go to 105 110 this is the end of
the apple growth story it's the third
inning remember thirty percent of
upgrade diatom six the fact that Apple
makes money hand over fist we talk all
the time about these incredible growth
stories of companies who make absolutely
no dough and it trades it eight times X
cash and China is seven percent Pendred